millions of years ago humans were near
the bottom of the food chain Predators
weather and diseases all posed the
threat of wiping the species out but
then thanks to Revolution humans went
from huddling in dark caves to building
full-blown cities how did that
happen this mysterious era was a time
when history wasn't officially recorded
but it brought on a ton of ation that
would be the building blocks of our
world today let's hop in our time
machine and take a trip back to the
prehistoric era okay first what is this
strange prehistoric era that you've
ended up in well this was a time in
history when humans began to develop the
world we have today it was comprised of
three main ages the Stone Age the Bronze
Age and the Iron Age the names of these
ages reflected the primary materials
that humans were using to make their
tools but these materials also provided
so much more than simple instruments
they inspired an entirely new society
and helped humans evolve into the new
world let's check it out the Stone Age
the Stone Age comprised three main eras
the Paleolithic Mesolithic and Neolithic
periods the stone age began over 3
million years ago and this was one of
the most critical ages for humans and
our Evolution one of the most
significant advancements of this time
was the creation of stone tools early
humans began making and using tools from
rocks and other raw materials around
them one of their tools was sharp
Pebbles that were used to cut and
sharpen other materials they were
essentially just sharpened rocks that
humans would hold to make more complex
and useful tools after humans mastered
this they moved on to sharpening other
Stones stones used for chopping these
could be used to cut wood or help
prepare food next their most complex
tool the hand axe these were made using
multiple techniques first you needed to
form the rock using a hard Hammer
technique once that's done you'd refine
the thin Edge using using a soft Hammer
technique today these tools seem
incredibly simple and you can make them
yourself just by looking at them but
millions of years ago these tools
required a detailed understanding of how
Stone Works and how it behaves under
certain
circumstances yeah this again sounds
really simple but by figuring this out
in the Stone Age humans proved they'd
made a significant leap in brain
function and problem
solving another another major Innovation
during this time was harnessing fire
fire provided shelter warmth and
protection for humans allowing them to
begin their Journey to the top of the
food chain after millions of years of
humans playing around with their newly
discovered tools they were able to
become much more than just a hunting and
Gathering Society this is where farming
came into play humans in the Mesolithic
period began experimenting with planting
food as the climate changed it became
easier to grow their own plants in the
soil and more types of food became
available farming also brought the
domestication of animals goats pigs and
cattle all had benefits for humans they
could be used for food clothing even
labor now once farming and domestication
started to take off well it brought a
shift in settlement patterns instead of
nomadic humans moving from cave to Cave
they were able to start building more
permanent
homes humans in the final period of the
Stone Age the Neolithic period built on
top of these inventions instead of just
experimenting with seeds humans began to
learn agricultural techniques and were
able to plant enough crops to feed their
settlements this period brought new
tools and technology and a completely
different social structure with more
food and permanent settlements the
population boomed this led to a division
of labor political structures and more
the Bronze Age from 3300 to 1200 BCE was
the Bronze Age one of the key factors of
this age was humans discovering how to
use metals like copper tin and of course
Bronze in their tools with these
materials they made more advanced
instruments and weapons ones that would
last longer and could be more
interesting since metal is more
malleable than Stone this also opened
the door for Artisans and experts to
begin working with bronze they created
art that was sought after and influenced
culture weapons and armor made of bronze
impacted how war was conducted at the
time but bronze materials weren't the
only New Kids on the Block the wheel was
invented this made it easier to move
people and supplies trade Roots between
settlements were created different
settlements could share or sell
resources amongst each other allowing
civilization to progress even faster
this led the way for urbanization and
the introduction of cities settlements
in places like Egypt and Greece
eventually grew to a point where the
population was so big it required some
sort of urban planning this created
cities Society evolved further trade
Administration and writing were all
starting to come into play but all of
this would have been impossible without
food during the Bronze Age Humanity
started to develop Mass farming
techniques this was possible because of
better tools and an enhanced knowledge
of how crops worked humans began to
understand what crops grew best where
and during what
seasons the Iron Age around 1200 BC
parts of Europe in the Middle East began
making tools with iron now this might
sound like a small Innovation but this
metal allowed Society to make massive
technological steps iron is much
stronger and more durable than copper
this allowed humans to build better
tools and weapons like good luck if you
were at war with your bronze armor and
weapons and had to face an army with all
Iron gear the societies with iron tools
tools were the ones in power iron was
also much easier to mine and more
readily available than copper this
allowed humans to make more tools that
were economically viable and more tools
means more food that can be harvested
more buildings that can be made the
opportunity for society to progress and
flourish now the process of making these
tools also required significant
Innovation smelting iron and being able
to forge and temper the material
required huge technological jumps but
cities weren't limited to making just a
few tools at a time they were becoming
production
powerhouses they could produce dozens or
hundreds of tools whenever they needed
iron working was so popular that over
the next couple hundred years it
expanded across the globe from Scotland
to Africa societies began using iron and
learning the methods of building tools
this allowed more more cities and
settlements to progress and prosper
expanded trade routes helped with the
progress more cities and cultures could
communicate with each other than never
before the creation of iron tools
facilitated the need for different
cities to trade and share resources
another essential tool invented during
this time was the iron plow this allowed
us to farm crops more efficiently than
ever before often creating a surplus of
food and of course more food allowed
populations to grow bigger all thanks to
these new found
Tools around 550 BCE the Iron Age gave
way to the age of classical Antiquity
marked by the beginning of humans
recording and documenting our own
history and the rest is well history
literally now what would happen if we
decided to go even further back to the
Cambrian Period a time before dinosaurs
existed well that sounds like a story
for another what
if